moving about three misfits Scouts being
this one town's last best hope against
the zombie apocalypses movie should have
been awesome what happened what happened
scouts guide to the zombie apocalypse -
scouts guide to the zombie apocalypse is
about three Scouts all of them have
different personalities personalities
you would probably think they would have
and they do you got the average one that
we're all going to gravitate to because
he's generally speaking most of us you
have this [ __ ] talker and you wonder how
he befriended these other Thun you have
the really kind of dopey fat awkward one
they're camping and Walter away they get
back into town and they find out the
town is now overrun with zombies this
movie is kind of what you would expect
it would be just a worse version of it
seriously starting from the beginning
the build-up to the zombies took way too
long they're camping they have tension
among their friends circle and you have
a few tit jobs here and there and you're
like dude I saw the trailer for this
movie you guys makeshift a bunch of
weapons and you kick a lot of zombie ass
let's get to that oh no not yet and what
feels like halfway through the movie the
zombies start filtering in and they're
running from zombies they're basically
the N throwdown most of the scenes you
saw in the trailer yeah that's the last
scene in the movie I'm not even gonna
call it the last act it's the last scene
of the last act seriously this movie was
a dragon it was boring hell on earth
gonna be born with a premise like this
this movie should have been the next
zombie land instead what you have is a
movie that probably would have been a
really funny episode of South Park in
fact I think that's how it went down
Trey Parker and Matt Stone the
brainstorming for a South Park episode
where three of them are Scouts and
zombie apocalypse and then the janitor
took their brainstorming notes from them
and took it home and that janitors 14
year old son wrote a script for this
movie seriously that's how prepubescent
the jokes are in this movie I didn't
really gravitate to any of the jokes all
the jokes were super easier like oh yeah
I get it
oh hey Ted ooh the strip club is called
Lawrence of Arabia funny I'm not saying
all the jokes sucked there were a couple
moments in this movie I was laughing
there was a badass scene in the end
where they actually start tearing
through zombies it's like I love that
[ __ ] the jokes that work are few and far
between and that one scene I like is the
variant of the movie this is gonna be a
nitpick at this point but you know when
you get out of moving you're super
disappointed you can just nitpick the
[ __ ] out of it I'm gonna nitpick this
right granted zombies don't exist we
don't know how they would act but the
zombies
this movie had skill it's just
inconsistent how much skill that have in
some scenes and don't have another scene
I could see where a zombies just tied up
he's off he's trying to bite somebody
that's all he knows how to do but in
another scene zombies are grabbing these
kids and throwing them and flipping them
around I'm like well zombies have
wrestling moves there's a zombie
stripper who has stripper moves I know
some people in the comment section are
gonna be like well zombies just operate
on muscle memory so they would know how
to fight if they did know how to fight
when they were human beings actually
somewhere the director this movie's
gonna be like yeah totally is what I was
going for it sure as in the end scouts
guide to the zombie apocalypse I wanted
a very simple premise I just wanted to
see Scouts kick ass against zombies it
is not hard to please me at that point
is pretty hard to [ __ ] that up
it didn't really please me and it
completely [ __ ] it up it wasn't that
funny it wasn't that exciting it wasn't
that interesting it was kind of boring
not gonna dog [ __ ] this movie up but I
will say Scouts guide to the zombie
apocalypse you're not gonna remember it
in t-minus one day yeah I already forgot
it seemed like the kind of movie that
the director of Paranormal Activity the
marked ones would pump out seriously
it's the same director it all comes
together right so scouts guide to the
zombie apocalypse have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more